all right Tony
uh where are you from urgent where'd you
grow up I grew up in Aurora Kentucky
which is in the western part of the
state near the uh Tennessee River on
Kentucky Lake
tell me about uh your childhood growing
up
well um single
um only child my father was an only
child my mother had seven brothers and
sisters
we were just the average family my
father went to the Korean war came back
opened up a Ashland gas station he had
other opportunities in Texas he was a
good salesman and a good organizer but
he landed in right on the river there
Tennessee River my mother was a waitress
at the state park we were the closest
home to the state park
and the state park was my playground so
the nearest Home was probably a mile
from ours
but I had the
playground sounds like a idyllic
childhood it was a lot of fun I wish my
children could go up grow up like that
but you you had a run-in with somebody
an Infamous I did in 1970
at the state park it was kin Lake State
Park
I had a run-in with uh John Wayne Gacy
and well actually I ran into him three
years later too but the first time you
met him was you were hold I was about a
month or a couple weeks from being 15.
hmm
what happened
um it was a typical Hot August Night I
was at the state park and I'd been
playing with some of the tourist kids
I'd ridden my bike across the golf
course over to the park property I was
sitting in the lobby he walks up to me
and he said uh are you a local I said
yes he said what's her to do around here
and he's dressed in a leisure suit a
black and brown leisure suit I was in
Orange swim trunks with a towel around
my neck
a city like fishing you like boating
it's a resort it's outdoor Paradise
hunting
he said no and then he I started to get
up he said what's there to do around
here
and I said are you into hiking or
sailing or camping and
he said no and then I started asking him
questions I said
um where are you from he said I'm from
Chicago I'm visiting some people down
here
and I said where he said Jonathan Creek
well I knew that was about four hours by
water four hours by land
so I started to get up again and he
asked me the question again so I went
ahead and stood up and I was starting to
get annoyed and uh
I said are you looking for liquor or are
you looking for for women I said this is
kind of a family style Resort
and as I started to walk off he said hey
would you like to have a beer
with me and I said sure
so we walked down to his room it was the
sixth room on the left
I knew most of the workers at the state
park but there was a new desk clerk
named Ella working that night and she we
had seen each other I had the keys to
the uh to some of the rooms where I
could get a fresh towel if I needed it
since my mother worked there I was a
fixture really on the property
so we go down to his room
he opens the door Jose old-fashioned
keys back then I walk in
I'll take a couple steps he walks in
behind me and he he takes his hand and
he grazes my behind my butt
and I thought that was a little weird
um
I thought maybe that was a mistake
I look to the right which was a typical
hotel room and the bathtub was
completely filled up filled to the top
with ice
and uh there's two chairs two beds the
TV was in between the chairs
I took a seat at the first
chair
and then he goes to a cooler and brings
back a beer it was a wiedemann and a red
white and black can
he hands me the beer
and then he goes over and shuts the
curtains
and
we were on the first floor
and my bike was parked just right
outside the window probably 30 40 feet
away
and he's closed the curtains he walks
past me
this would have been the picture glass
window here this would have been the
restroom
as he goes past me
he starts talking to me just asking me
questions and you know what I did what
my parents did and things like that
and he locks the door
and now I'm starting to feel well that's
a little weird too because initially I
thought we was going to have kind of a
man-to-man conversation I'd been around
my dad's my dad had a sawdust
clandestine gambling joint behind a gas
station
and he'd let me hang out with all the
men in there he'd also uh I had when I
was 13. I got on my dad about not being
able to mow yards because we didn't have
any neighbors and he said I'll take you
down to the lake where all the gods come
in let you clean fish
so he told me to go in and start talking
to the guides about cleaning fish and my
pitch to them was while you're getting
your gas your boat gassed up for
tomorrow and your bait everything ready
for tomorrow I can take care of this for
you and that was kind of my little side
hustle when I was 13. but anyway back to
uh
he uh he seemed to start getting
agitated so I was drinking my beer on
this next trip through he asked me if I
like sex books
and in my mind I was thinking Playboy
and I'd only seen Playboy a few times on
the back of the bus with one of my
friends uh he would take the Playboy
from his older brother and all of us
would gather around on the back of a
school bus in a rural road where we were
all bumping heads trying to see the
centerfold
and so he takes the suitcase out sets it
on the bed
opens it up it's full of books there's
probably a magazine there's probably 50
or 60 magazines there
um I reach over start Fanning through
them
and I didn't see anything that I thought
I would like so he grabs a couple and
just hands them to me
I set back and I start thumbing through
them they're all boys
so
at this time when I'm going through the
uh the magazines he's back in the
restroom he's I hear the faucet come on
and off next time he comes out he's got
a towel wrapped around his neck
and uh at the that time when he came out
he locks the deadbolts on the door
so
now things start to slow motion kicks in
on me I think this is not right
something's wrong I'm I'm in a bad
situation here
so
I got the same feeling about a year
before me and a fellow that was a friend
of mine tried to swim across Kentucky
Lake which was almost a while a mile
wide we got halfway across and he starts
to panic I said you got to roll over
and start swimming on your back until we
can get some help
and I started looking for a buoy
someplace for us to find something to
float luckily in a few minutes the
border patrol or the
Lake Patrol came through and we were
able to get out of there but I had the
same feeling I was starting to panic a
little bit
he comes back through
and I said hey there's there's just Boys
in these books
and he says I got something else you
might like
so he goes to the other side of the bed
puts another suitcase up on the bed
opens it up it's full of shackles and
handcuffs
and chains
and inside my mind I'm thinking this is
this is bad I got to get out of here
so I take my beer it was about half full
I set it down to my left heel
and I said the next time he goes to the
bathroom I'm going to take this cooler
and I'm either going to throw it through
the window
or I'm going to move it where I can get
away so he goes in the bathroom again
and his uh demeanor
his his
eyes start to get a little squinty
um
he was changing he was he was looking at
me when he was sneering at me when he
would walk by
and I'm pretty big kid for 15 but I I
knew I didn't have enough this was a
powerful powerfully built man
and so as soon as he goes in the
bathroom and the faucet comes on I grab
the cooler I take it over into the far
corner
right by the window
and when he comes back out after he had
mentioned the the chains and the
shackles and all that stuff
I said do you have any snacks
and while he's looking at me I kicked my
beer over
and he's he act kind of
uh
disoriented for a second he said no I
don't have any snacks and I said can I
have another beer so he looks where the
cooler was he didn't see the cooler
and he goes starts looking for the
cooler well he goes he walks past me and
around both beds and I hit the door
and I'm hitting them unlock them
unlocking the chain I'm unlocking the
deadbolt and I opened the door and just
as I step out he grabs me and he hit he
he grabs at me he hits me a couple of
times but I just kept back pedaling
because I didn't have on a shirt for him
to grab I didn't have any shoes
so I back on out of there walked past
the desk clerk Ella
and I get get on my bike and I'm a
little shaken but I didn't know who he
was I just figured if some weird weird
guy
um
but I'd been around enough men with my
father's um
backroom gambling stat establishment
that I knew that was that was not normal
so I'll get home I go across the golf
course the dudes flying up off my bike
hit me it was wet
um I had to cross the road and go up a
hill we lived up on a hill I had a
German Shepherd named Vaughn and Vine
started to bark like I was a stranger
until I got about halfway up the hill
then he he knew it was me so he started
whimpering
my mom opens the door she says where you
been I was getting ready to come looking
for you
I said mom you're not going to believe
what happened to me
and so I told her the whole story
my mom smoked about three cigarettes a
day but she backed up against the
kitchen counter
and lit a cigarette and I could tell she
was real concerned
and I said this weird guy tried to trap
me in his room
At first she was just taking it in but
then she got more nervous and more
nervous
she worked there she worked at the state
park but she and she was a desk clerk
too now she started as a waitress when
she was young
uh Associates of law talked to your dad
about it when he gets home
and we knew it'd be midnight before he
got home that's when all the gambling
stopped he ran the gambling from one in
the morning or from one in the afternoon
to midnight one in the morning
so
fast forward three years we still live
by the park that's still my playground
I'm working at the marina now
and I was taking on a lot of
responsibilities at the marina I was in
charge of the houseboat rentals and
other things I worked with a big Samoan
guy he was 6'4 his name was Pete
so me and Peter sitting out
by the gas docks at the marina
and
I went in the five in the morning to one
in the afternoon shift and I thought
well I'm going to check the wind see if
how calm the lake is I'm going to walk
to the front of the marina and see if
it's black capping or if we can go water
skiing when I get off
so I walked to the front of the marinas
turn the corner and I bump into a guy
and for my first reaction was I said
excuse me I step aside he steps aside
and it was healed
now I'm almost 18 now
and I said Hey do you remember me
and he said no I don't remember you and
I said you're from Chicago I said you
remember me
and he said no I don't well I was kind
of full of piss and vinegar at that age
so I kind of went chest to chest with
him I said yes you do I'm not 14 anymore
oh I was almost 15.
and by that time my boss walks out Mr
Wilhelm
and he says everything okay so
we went our separate ways
uh
then
I guess it's 78
December 78
um
I'm older now I'm driving a lot of the
kids I went to school high school and
college with and in that part of the
country had moved to Nashville
I'd been in Nashville partying we had
closed down some bars and Printers Alley
which was a big section of Nashville
Tennessee
I was hungover I was hungry it was
December 23rd I believe
I was so I started home I went by
Rivergate Mall I was going to get a
present for my mom and dad and I ended
up getting them one of those
boxes of cheese and salami and all that
stuff so I walked to have it wrapped
there was a bunch of ladies on a
horseshoe horseshoe tables out in the
intersection of the mall wrapping gifts
I set the get the gift up on the table
and I sat down and I looked behind them
I see this row of newspapers
and I don't know if it was my brain
kicked in before my eyes kicked in
but I as I'm staring at these newspapers
I couldn't really see the headlines but
I could see this guy's face
and I started getting cold chills
so
I got up walked over there and every
step I was saying to myself that's the
guy that's the guy that tried to trap me
in the in the hotel room that's the guy
I ran into at the marina four years
later
so I get home
and I was telling my I didn't live at
home then but I stopped by the house to
tell my mom the story she said well I'm
going to call this Chicago Police
Department I said don't do that Mom I
said
you know what's the usage what she did
it anyway
so she called the Chicago Police
Department
she didn't know that the Chicago Police
Department didn't have the um
they didn't really have the case they
had no jurisdiction it was the Cook
County Sheriff who had the jurisdiction
and this police officer said
he kind of blew my mom off he said
ma'am do you think we really need
someone's help a ladies helping Kentucky
when we got all these bodies under this
guy's house
so she said well I just wanted you to
make a report so he took her name took
my name put the date on it
and uh
we kind of forgot about it
then
in
I guess 96 or 97 a detective from
the Cook County Sheriff call me he
wanted me to tell him the story so I did
he would just ask me questions
but he wouldn't really give me any
feedback so I've told him the story
then 2007 a reporter from the Chicago
Tribune called me
and he had a lot of knowledge
he had more knowledge of course he had
the
he had the benefit of being after the
effect after the fact
but he said I want to talk to you about
this encounter so we talked about it we
talked for 45 minutes
and he said he believed and I do too now
that Casey
cruised the Dells of Wisconsin
Lake Geneva
Lake of the Ozarks
and Kentucky Lake
and he said they have a lot of what they
call drownings
but he don't believe there were
drownings he believed these young men
were killed
so
we kind of parted you know he said he'd
get back in touch with me and he asked
me if I wanted to talk to him again to
call him I never did this never really
bothered me it still don't bother me but
until I got to be 50 55 years old then I
started thinking about it
and I I probably told
20 people about it
and I was relaying it to my son and he
said well you should write it down so I
did
I wrote it down I think the reason
though that I got away from this guy
was
because my mom and dad
just let me I had unlimited freedom
and a lot of fathers
in a back room wasn't hardly as big as
this room but when you got gambling and
poker and dice and drinking and
um I was five or six years old and my
dad would
let me walk around in there not to hear
guys cussing and not hear
every you know you hear everything my
dad never covered my ears
um
and this place was like
the lake at that time was a boom town
because Interstate 24 hadn't come in so
everyone traveling north to south would
pass through
where my dad had his business and there
was plus there was an airport behind it
and my dad
when he got home from the Korean War he
wanted to have fun my grandmother said
he's going to dedicate the rest of his
life to having fun because his ship was
shot a couple times
one song Harbor
me and around him died he told my
grandmother he was going to work but he
was going to have fun he turned down a
couple of jobs in Houston
with oil companies and that's that's
really the reason he
leaned towards uh I think opening up a
Ashland oil gas station
so
my dad had a couple of mechanics that
really ran the gas station he worked in
the back room
they're named for scroggs and jamer they
were Kentucky boys country boys could
fix anything can make anything
I'm five or six years old I'm hanging
out in the gas station and I for a
couple of months I'd been asking him to
make me a go-kart
or make me a mini bike
well they did they made me a mini bike
and this was
this was near a place called Golden Pond
in the
Treasury and revenue agents named it the
Golden Pond because every time the
whiskey Stills would get
crushed by the by the feds they said the
whiskey would roll down the mountains
and form a Golden Pond
so that's how it got its name
I'm behind the gas station I'm across
the airport riding this mini bike and I
start up a trail
and I'd seen these guys come and go at
the gas station and I knew because a big
part of my dad's business was
putting bladders in these cars
putting extra shocks on these cars he
didn't do it but the guys working for
him did because they were hauling
whiskey to Evansville to Cincinnati to
to Nashville
and there was a couple of guys that kind
of stood out as as haulers they'd make
sure their cars was clean
because they didn't want to look like
they were coming from back roads
so there was one one guy in particular
his name was scooper and he was kind of
a James Dean looking character
he so I'm riding my mini bike I go up
this mountain
on this Trail they had a lot of power
too it was a custom-made bike
a deer jumps out in front of me and I I
kind of crashed this kind of went over
as it went over there was a man I could
hear these men arguing and they were
arguing in a whiskey still
and so I looked at him and I thought oh
that's just guys making whiskey and here
I'm six years old but I know what's
going on I go back to my mini bike
and then I hear a fight break out
between these guys and I hear a guy let
out a whale
and I thought I recognized one of the
guys as one of those one of the drivers
that used to drive the whiskey
and
I didn't know what had happened to the
guy
so I I get back to the station
I didn't mention it to my dad just
another
another incident of men gathered
doing something
a few days later
my dad tells me this guy died
and they had stabbed him in the femoral
artery
and so I told my dad about it at dinner
and he said well we're not going to
mention that anymore
and
so we never talked about it much
but
um
again everyone thinks that they grow up
in a regular family
and I did too because you know I had
friends and
but some of the church ladies would
they they wouldn't look Us in the eye
Mark I feel like I'm doing all talking
no you're doing great you're doing great
what kind of work have you done in your
life
well I've always had a
a work ethic so I started working when I
was 13. I was working at the marina I
was I was kind of hanging around at the
marina went to college got a couple of
degrees I actually worked for Tennessee
Valley Authority when I first got out of
college
I was
kind of wild I wasn't mean but I was
wild a lot of drinking a lot of parties
fell into pills when I was young
never got into coke or heroin or
anything like that
but to support my habit and I bought a
used sailboat
my grandfather was a painter in Miami
I sailed around Kentucky like a couple
seasons and then I needed some work on
my boat so I towed it down to Miami left
it with my grandfather
some of the people in the area where he
lived in Miami they were mostly Blue
Collar Working Families he was a painter
but he he was really a drinker he'd
paint about three days a week and drink
the other
four
I got to know some of the boys around
there they seen my boat in his backyard
when he got it finished he said he
called me he said some of these guys
want to test your boat I said fine let
them you know I kind of grew up with
them when I was down there visiting him
um
in about a year
I'd call and say it's my boat okay and
say yeah they brought it back and then
for then they quit bringing it back so
so I went down to investigate
these guys were bringing um
bales of marijuana into the country they
go out every night bring it back in
some of them ended up getting in trouble
a boat got confiscated I got my boat
back
and then I got contacted by some guys
some Colombian guys that wanted me to
take over their role
going out six to eight miles meeting
them bringing
bringing marijuana in so probably
brought in seven or eight tons of
marijuana
uh
gotten got arrested for it
beat the charge down there and then they
picked it up in Western Kentucky
and charged me with this distribution
I played out went to the federal prison
for a little while from 86 to 89
.
since
since I went to
they rate you when you go into federal
prison you're either a one which is a
low level White Collar criminal or
you're a six which is the worst to the
worst
when you're in the federal prison I was
a one
I started out in camps I started out in
Lexington went to Terre Haute went to
Duluth
and went back to Marion Illinois which
was right across the street from the
only level six that replaced Alcatraz
so
I was a model prisoner
stayed busy played tennis played them
back the prison basketball team
one day my counselor comes said I want
you to go home you've been good I want
you to go home for five days I said okay
so I thought it was a chance to spend
some time with my children
I go home and when I get home I become
Afflicted with pneumonia
so I went to my family doctor
one of the rules when you leave federal
prison on a furlough you're not supposed
to take any medicine so I called the
prison
I said I've got pneumonia they give me
three medications they said bring them
in with you
so
when you're in the federal at that time
when you're in the federal prison system
your counselors the correctional
officers would say things like if you
mess up your boy we'll send you on up
the ladder and you'll end up in in
Marion Illinois in the new Alcatraz
and nobody paid much attempts they were
just kind of kidding with you
so I come back in after my furlough I
set my three bottles of medicine up
there
they said take him across the street and
lock him up even though I got permission
to bring them in
I was antibiotic one was Valium
because they wanted my lungs to relax
so they put me in the new Alcatraz in
the level six Penitentiary on H unit
which level one wasn't supposed to be in
a level six
so
I only had a year to go
so I spent the last 11 months basically
in the in the toughest prison
um
but getting back when you first entered
the prison these these guards and these
counselors they say if you mess up we'll
send you
to the new Alcatraz and we'll put you on
the reins with a guy named Sonny Burkett
Sonny Burkett had been in the in the
in the riots in New York and the prison
rights of New York he was he had burned
snitches with uh
blow torches
he uh he had 1800 years and he was on H
unit
in Marion Illinois
so I'd been in there about two hours I'm
laying on my cell
and you don't even have bars the it's
the place is so bad they take you to the
dentist
in a cage they'll put you in a cage like
like you were a big cat or something
they'll pull you to the dentist
you had to go through 15 or 20
electronic doors to get back there to
where the the
sales were
so all all these years these three years
they'd say or two years they'd say you
mess up here we'll send you to Marion
Illinois and put you on the range with
sunny Burkett
Sonny had killed 16 inmates in the
prison
he'd been in the Attica riots and they'd
they transfer the worst of the worst
state prisoners to the divorce Federal
Prison
so I'm laying there on my cell it's all
in my on my bed it's all concrete
there's there's no way to
to make a tool out of anything
and there's no bars on the doors either
it's just a window
in the Halls are real wide
because
I guess for security purposes
so all of a sudden this face pops up in
my cell door
and he said uh you're new aren't you
I said yeah I just got here
he said you know who I am
I said no
he said I'm Sonny Burkett you've heard
of me haven't you
and I said well I think I have heard of
you sonny
and it was like looking into the eyes of
a Rottweiler
he could be scared of me
and I said well I don't have any reason
to be scared of you I just got here
he said you have any King which is an
orange drink you mix up
and I said I just got here I hadn't had
time to go to commissary or put in an
order for anything
he said well when you get some King I'll
trade you some coffee
and as he's talking to me this guy pops
up across the hall half his face is a
spider web
and I found out later this guy's name
was hacksaw he escaped from all the
other penitentiaries level fives the
level fours
and he had kind of gone crazy but he
knew who Sonny was
so he's shaking his head no all the time
Sonny's talking to me
so sending student Sonny leaves he goes
hey
he goes that guy will try to trick you
into taking going to the law library
he'll take it to the law library and
kill you that's where he kills everyone
and I said well I wasn't going to go to
law library I'm about out of here I said
what about you hacksaw he said well I
got 10 more years
he said but I'll get out of here I said
this is escape proof you'll never get
out of here it's a level six
Penitentiary I said you can't get out of
here he goes oh yeah I can he said
they'll transfer me to another unit
he said the last time I escaped I went
to Mexico he went into a big story
so
sunny
I'd been in there a few days and they
brought my clothes over
they I filled out a list for commissary
where you can get oranges and apples
he comes back we start trading items
I received USA Today and
a couple other newspapers
um I was there reading one of my
newspapers one day
and the only time you really got out of
your sale the place was so dangerous
is if you go to the shower and back
which is twice a week so I seen this
Shadow walk by my door
and then a new this Newsweek come flying
under my cell door
and it was Carlos later who had been one
of the
members of the first big cartels and
Columbia
it had a note on it
it said I see you get a couple
newspapers I get a couple magazines
let's trade so we did
so then he got to stop him by myself
um
but everybody in the new Alcatraz was
long-termers I wasn't a long-termer most
of them were violent I wasn't really
about I'd been in a few brawls but I
wasn't really violent
um
so I I was lucky to get out of there I
thought
finally my mother called the congressman
so much to get me out of there that uh
I think I was the last level one they
were put in a level six
got out in 89 started my life over
moved from Western Kentucky
to Lexington Kentucky just to be close
to my children
um a buddy came by from college
went with him up to that point I was you
get all the bad jobs washing dishes
mopping floors even with a couple
college degrees had a degree in
accounting a degree in criminal justice
but I still wouldn't wasn't getting any
any work until I got an insurance
license then I started making some money
getting my life back together
I had an insurance office above a
grocery store in Lexington and Nick it
was a a strip center
but some offices were upstairs and there
were some people that had the office
next to me who had contracts to do
carpet installation loads and Home Depot
well they hired people all over the
state
I heard some guys in in the eastern part
of the state they would come in weekly
and work two or three days and go back
one day they heard me talking about
buying a truck I was in the mood in the
market for a truck a used truck I was
going to keep my automobile but I'm just
looking for a truck
these guys were from Floyd County
Kentucky
and then I'd seen them wave at them say
hi whatever
they said hey we heard you was looking
for a truck
and I said yeah I'm still looking for a
truck they said we know God's got one
for sale
I said okay I said give me his phone
number I said well they don't have a
phone he lives over in Floyd County
you'll probably have to come over there
and check it out
so they left a few days later the guy
goes hey I'm going over to Floyd County
you want to ride over with me and he
showed me the picture of this truck
again you see he wants four thousand
dollars for it
I said okay when I closed down the
office we'll we'll go over there
so I ride over to
Floyd County Kentucky with this guy I'd
worked all over the eastern part of the
state
and he says we got to go to my brother's
first but I got to pick him up at Kmart
so he stops and picks his brother up at
Kmart and his brother comes out of Kmart
with a large tent on his shoulder I've
never seen his brother before but I said
where's his where's his car
he said I'll be they mumbles something
he said we're going to go by his house
first
so
her now this feeling I'd I'd had when I
was 15 starting to kick in a little bit
I barely know this guy he knows I got
four thousand dollars in my pocket
we picked up his brother who's got a
Sleepy Eye
and he's got a tent on his shoulder we
get to his house I did need to go to the
restroom
so it's it's up a holler it's it's kind
of um
you know wooden frame house
we walk in the front door and we're
standing there I said where's the guy
with the truck and they said oh we got
to go we got to go over to his house
well he motions to the guy to go out and
get the tent
out of that we were in a van we're in a
Chevy van
so I said well I'm going to go ahead and
go to the restroom
so I go to the restroom
I get in this it's a small restroom
and I thought these guys are going to
kill me they're going to kill me for
this four thousand dollars
so I checked the window and it was hard
to open and it was small but I finally
got it open
I took the shower curtain down and the
door didn't really have a lock on it so
I pressed it up against the doorknob put
it against the tub
it was starting to get dark I crawled
out of this window
I don't know exactly where I am
but I know I'm going to get away from
this house
so I walked in the woods for
probably an hour
I'd really kind of lost my bearing so I
would walk a while and I'd listen a
while I thought maybe I could hear a car
on a on a road I thought maybe I could
hear a creek a river
or anything finally I did start hearing
a car
so I walked to a convenience store
I finally I was leery about getting out
on the road
and call someone to come pick me up
so that was one of the experiences I had
in Appalachia
you had some some brushes with uh almost
dying it seems well couple
my I I think I got this from my father
my father always rooted for the underdog
but he he had a
um he sort of sought out
illicit Adventures I did too it was a
thrill for me
I still have a little of that in me I
don't know if it's
I'm not really a gambler but I think
that replaced what
some people would call gambling is it
just the adrenaline I think so
um
but when I think back about those days I
I almost
seems like a different person doesn't
really seem like something I would have
done but I'm I was pretty wild
we living in the country live in the
rural areas we
we had a there was a bridge across
Kentucky lake called eggnospheric Bridge
it's about 80 feet from the water
and we started jumping off of it and
then we started doing flips off of it
and then a couple guys quit
jumping off it then we started doing it
night
that was more of a thrill because you
couldn't necessarily time it
then some boys down in uh
down in Southern Tennessee found out we
were jumping off of it and they wanted
to come up there and challenge us
so
I they wouldn't jump off at night
but then it had these the top of the
bridge was just the steel girders
so then
I climbed up the steel girders and
jumped off and this boy from Tennessee
said well if you'll do that I will he
jumped off and broke his leg
and then he sent some cousins up there
like a couple weeks later
and it got to be a contest but
that's just adrenaline
seeking adrenaline
Tony what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
this
how many you're 67. I'll be yeah I'll be
68 September I think the most important
lesson is
you have to give your kids opportunities
to mess up
so they can protect themselves
I think they have to be students of
human behavior
and by hanging around groups of men
whether it was at my
the back room of my dad's gambling
establishment or
in a room with seven or eight guides
fishing guides cleaning fish
and you have to be a good listener
and I thank you you'll you'll figure
things out I think these helicopter
parents are doing a real disservice for
their children and I know it's necessary
today
is your ability to figure out what to do
in in tough situations at an early age
is what saved your life yeah exactly
all right Tony thank you so much for
sharing your stories you're welcome it
was a fascinating
thank you very much